la serenísima ahora el epicentro mundial
de la cultura y con razón la bienal de
venecia la gran con creación de arte
contemporáneo acaba de abrir sus puertas
este año uno de los artistas más
esperados es paloma cof vivían jarquín
ucrania cuando comenzó la guerra
no quería dejar jarque pero con los
bombardeos todo quedó destruido
completamente devastado cogí a mi madre
de 92 años y a mi mujer y huimos porque
me dije que no podíamos quedarnos más
tiempo ni siquiera puedo luchar allí
pero ahora puedo ayudar organizamos
subastas benéficas para vender arte y
enviar dinero allí a los voluntarios y
al ejército
aquí está su obra llamada fuente de
agotamiento una instalación con 78
embudos de bronce el trabajo fue ex
filtrado desde ucrania tras el inicio de
los bombardeos
elegir las sociedades especialmente las
del mundo democrático están al límite no
están dispuestas a proteger los ideales
y principios en los que se basa la vida
y esta fuente habla de lluís
en los jardines de la bienal un segundo
espacio organizado por la delegación
ucraniana expone obras creadas tras el
inicio de la ofensiva rusa el objetivo
era afirmar la independencia cultural de
ucrania
estamos aquí para representar a nuestro
país nuestra identidad y nuestra cultura
lo que está ocurriendo en ucrania es
también una guerra de dos culturas la
cultura ucraniana está siendo
literalmente demolida por los misiles
rusos pero también por la narrativa rusa
y nosotros estamos aquí para luchar
contra esta narrativa no muy lejos de
allí el pabellón ruso permaneció cerrado
este año
el pabellón ruso está cerrado porque los
artistas y el conservador se han
retirado y el comisario del pabellón ha
decidido dejarlo cerrado para su uso en
las redes sociales los artistas rusos
que iban a participar dijeron no hay
lugar para el arte cuando los civiles
están
la bienal permanecerá abierta al público
hasta el 27 de noviembre